thousands gathered in this Plaza in
Santa Cruz to demand the release of
opposition Governor Luis Fernando
Camacho they want to be called as
Witnesses in the ongoing investigation
into the role the governor played in
2019 when former president Evo Morales
was forced out of office
Sanchez says he was part of the protest
that pushed Eva Morales to resign after
being accused of committing fraud
our rights are being violated and we
come here to let them know what they are
doing is wrong we want the government
released and we are tired of a
government that does not respect the
people we voted for
[Applause]
the government says that what happened
in 2019 was a coup but people here say
that Eva Morales committed fraud and
that is why he was forced out of office
people here are convinced that the
country's Judiciary is being used to go
after political opponents and that's why
Luis Fernando Camacho and others were
detained and that's why many are vowing
to remain on the streets because they
believe that this country's democracy is
at risk
but not everyone agrees Paola Aguilar
owns a shop in Santa Cruz she says that
she was attacked by those opposing the
government of evil Morales many are now
Camacho supporters she dared questioned
the protests that were hurting her
business and says she is afraid the same
thing could happen again
my children called me and told me not to
come home because people are outside and
they're going to set us on fire I have
two children who are disabled so imagine
what I felt then they took my phone off
and made me kneel they said they're
going to spray gasoline on me and set me
on fire
[Music]
there are historic divisions in Bolivia
between the highlands that are mostly
indigenous and the lowlands represented
by provinces like Santa Cruz
a stronghold of the opposition and the
Heart of Bolivia's economy
says the conflict we see today started
in 2016 when Evo Morales failed to
recognize the results of a referendum
that denied him the right to run for
office for a fourth term
this political crisis started in 2016.
our Constitution that is redrafted by
Eva morale says a president can be in
office for two terms ever was three
times in office and wanted to run again
he lost a referendum and still found an
excuse to try to remain in office this
made a lot of people angry and this is
what we see today
the International Community has asked
the government to guarantee Governor
Camacho's right to a fair trial
until then he will remain in pre-trial
detention while his supporters continue
to protest to get him released
something that is unlikely to happen
anytime soon